moving to Washington the Senate majority
leader says he does not have the votes
yet to block Democrats from calling
witnesses in president Trump's
impeachment trial some Republicans are
reacting to reports of new allegations
from former national security adviser
John Bolton Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill for us Nancy good morning this does
not sound like good news for the White
House but how bad is it well they're
increasingly concerned Tony one senior
administration official who's been
deeply involved in impeachment strategy
put it at DEFCON 2 the White House now
has just a couple of days to try to
limit the number of Republicans who
cross party lines they can't win an
election so they're trying to steal an
election it's not happening folks
stumping in New Jersey President Trump
said he wasn't worried about the battle
in Washington but overnight his former
national security adviser was clearly on
his mind as mr. Trump tweeted why didn't
John Bolton complain about this nonsense
a long time ago his comments came after
his legal team wrapped up three days of
opening arguments but they want to make
it in P chable if it's just the wrong
idea inside the president's head they
urged the jury to ignore new revelations
from the president's former national
security adviser who according to the
New York Times writes in an upcoming
book that the President did condition
aid to Ukraine on investigations into
the Biden's are you going to allow
proceedings on impeachment to go from a
New York Times report about someone that
says what they hear is in a manuscript
but it has had an impact Republican
senators met for a frank talk Tuesday
about the way forward
that's where Senate leader Mitch
McConnell told his colleagues that they
don't yet have the votes to block
witness testimony it is very likely that
I'm going to conclude that yes we do
need to hear from witnesses many
Republicans still insist that's a waste
of time
that gets us into this endless cycle of
and this drags on for weeks and months
in the middle of a presidential election
some have
suggested simply allowing senators to
read Bolton's book in a secured room
it's not good enough there is no
substitute for a witness speaking under
oath to the Senators one notable
Republican now coming to Bolton's
defense former White House chief of
staff John Kelly who says he believes
John Bolton the Q&A portion of this
trial gets underway in just a few hours
senators will be able to write down
their questions to the house managers or
the president's defense on these cards
that QA will go on for two days with a
vote on witnesses likely to take place
on Friday Gail
all right Nancy have another interesting
day in Washington thank you very much